foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar titled
panel presentation automating high
throughput luminix assays for Multiplex
Gene and protein analysis this webinar
is part of the sixth annual laboratory
automation virtual event and I'm Susie
Valdez of Labyrinth and I will be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
labroots and sponsored by luminex a data
storing company for more information
about luminex go to
luminexcorp.com so let's get started
before we begin I want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
and we encourage you to First
participate by communicating with other
attendees using our new live chat
feature during the presentations you can
find that live chat located on the right
of your screen you can also participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click Send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation now if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation click on the help desk
button located at the bottom of your
screen within the navigation bar or from
the lobby I now present today's speaker
Dr chiffon yelbauer a product manager at
quantity Gene gene expression assays and
luminix instruments and Dr Bonnie story
a product manager software at laboratory
automation for a complete biography of
our speakers please visit the biography
tab at the left of your screen welcome
to both of you you may now begin your
presentation
thank you very much for the kind
introduction Susie
um as Susie mentioned we are speaking on
behalf of luminex Corporation today both
my colleague Dr Bonnie Suri and myself
are employees of Thelma Fisher
Scientific and we're an official partner
of luminix so welcome to this
presentation about automating high
throughput luminix essays for Multiplex
Gene and protein analysis
we are honored to speak today on behalf
of luminex the dear soaring company here
at this event as mentioned we are from
thermal Fisher Scientific and official
partner of luminex here you can see um
Thermo Fisher at a glance where we pride
ourselves in being the world leader
um in serving science as you can see by
these impressive numbers
at our core we're scientists in our
purpose is to enable our customers to
fulfill their scientific purpose we
really take pride in our mission which
is to enable our customers to make the
world healthier cleaner and safer and we
offer products and solutions that enable
our customers to push the boundaries of
innovation
here's today's uh agenda that I'll be
presenting together with my colleague Dr
Bonnie Sur from our lab automation group
I'll first walk you through some
introductions on high throughput
screening and I'll present to you our
invitrogen for Carter Plex and quantity
uniflex essays for Multiplex protein and
gene expression analysis and then Bonnie
is going to take over and talk to you
about all that automation Solutions and
also present our solution for automating
our luminex based assays here we'll be
focusing on quantity and flex essays for
automation
as mentioned we offer products and
solutions that enable our customers to
push really the boundaries of innovation
we're pushing these boundaries with our
Solutions like the ones presented here
in this case catering to high throughput
screening needs and
um I will walk you through some of the
examples today the workflow of High
throughput screens usually includes
three main steps you first have your
screening experiment where you can
screen thousands and thousands of
compounds depending on the goals that
you have with your screening experiments
The Next Step would be that after the
screening is over you have to prepare
these samples for analysis so there you
could be looking at hundreds of
thousands of wells and many many 96 or
384 well plates that you have to prepare
for the analysis which is the the third
step here as shown on this slides and
here the the key takeaway is is you want
to measure your key biomarkers outcome
of your screening with the goal of
finding a leads that works for your path
way or for your condition that you're
investigating so this analysis can be
either for RNA proteins metabolites or
other omics parameters
as part of the analysis of data analysis
tool and platform is also needed and
this is something that's sometimes
overlooked but I want to stress the
importance of this as well in order to
reduce the time to result and to
increase the efficiency of your high
throughput screen many labs are looking
into automating several steps or the
whole workflow and will present some
solutions here today to do this with two
particular assays
today I'd like to present to you high
throughput analysis solutions for RNA or
protein measurements and automation
solutions that we propose for these
assays at Domo Fisher we offer in
vitrogen quantity in flex and
procardoplex essays that are especially
well suited for high throughput
Multiplex gene expression or protein
analysis out as I'll explain to you in
the next few slides here
this table that you see here shows a
comparison of several specifications for
these assays on the left the quantity on
the right the cardiflex essay notably
you can see that you can measure up to
80 genes so rnas and up to 80 proteins
with these acids in each well of a 96 or
3d4 wall plates
combined with a simple sample prep
requirement these acids are really
perfect tools for high throughput needs
you can run a wide variety of sample
types from many different species
depending on your needs these acids are
analyzed and therefore require a luminex
instrument for readouts you can see a
suit of luminex instruments here at the
bottom which by the way you can also
purchase directly from thermal fissure
scientific
and the reason for running these assays
on luminex instruments is because they
rely on the well-established so-called
luminex x-map technology which stands
for multiple
multi-analyze profiling excuse me in
briefs luminex invented small magnetic
particles or beads that are dyed and
that are coated with a different mixture
of dyes which provide a unique
fluorescent emission to different beats
and therefore enabling the the concept
of multiplexing
developers and take advantage of this
principle to build Multiplex assays that
can analyze up to 80 targets for RNA and
r80 targets for proteins and we use
um specific oligos antibodies to capture
these targets from various sample
matrices
a simplified model for both scenarios is
shown here in the center where we show
the antibodies coated to the beads in
the center and to the right we show the
oligos bounds to these luminex beats
which then built the scaffold to capture
the targets and then do the signal
amplification as with the quantity
implex fancy notably Thermo Fisher
Scientific is the only supplier to offer
both protein and gene expression
Multiplex assays on the luminex platform
and on the right hand side you can see a
nice example of a cell cultural
stimulation experiment from which the
the same sample was then analyzed for
gene expression using a 36 Plex quantity
and Plex panel and for protein
expression using a 20 Plex th1 th2
cytokine chemokine panel from our
procontoplex suite of assays this
analysis will provide you with answers
from many if not all your key biomarkers
for both RNA and proteins and I will
show you some data for this experiment
in a different slide
from official scientific as I mentioned
is the only
um company to offer both protein and
gene expression REO Multiplex acids on
the luminex platform and here I'm
showing you some key benefits of both of
these acids that are now also available
in 3d4 well format for higher
throughputs demand the procardoplex and
the quarantine Plex acids are also
tested and validated on the new
intelliflex platform you can see an
image on the right of this new
instrument and we could show an
excellent correlation when running the
assay on various zoominix instrument
types and comparing it to the results
from the intelliflex instrument some key
benefits of the procardoplex essay are
shown on the left hand side is mentioned
up to 80 proteins from a small volume of
sample we have a lot of different off
the shelves but also custom panels for
this for this assay
and you get very consistent results you
can scale easily from 96 to 34 while
plate without
um use and losing performance on the
right hand side some key benefits of the
quantity in Plex essay this is a direct
from sample assay meaning you do not
have to isolate or purify the RNA you go
directly from your light state or you
imagine it into the assay and there is a
huge
um
huge array of different panels available
both custom and now also off the shelf
panels
here is an elegant example as I
mentioned earlier of the concepts of two
applications on one luminex instrument
showing some data of the experiment I
mentioned earlier so in this experiment
u937 cells were stimulated either with
PMA or with LPS for 24 or 48 hours
respectively after the experiment was
was done the supernatant was taken off
and measured using a picardaplex panel
the th1 th2 cytokine chemokine 20 Plex
panel here in the cells themselves were
light and then analyzed on a quantine
Plex 36 Plex panel for both gene
expression and protein analysis on the
right I'm showing two examples of two
Targets R8 and mcp1 for these two
Targets we found that there's an
excellent correlation between the the
transcript and the expressed protein as
you can see by the unstimulated versus
the stimulate con condition we're both
the RNA in the protein amount or
relative amounts are increasing
post-stimulation for both targets
now I'd like to provide you with some
details about these luminex acids and
we'll start with our procartiplex acid
for Multiplex protein detection we
recently launched as I mentioned the 3D
format of these acids as well as a quick
recap on the right hand side I'm showing
a a little scheme of how the luminix
x-map technology works again you have a
set of magnetic microspheres that are
color coded with combinations of red and
infrared fluorophores each beat set is
coated with a reagent specifically to a
particular bioassay in this case an
capture antibody which allows you to
capture and detect several specific
analytes from a single sample lasers in
the luminex instruments then excites the
internal Dives that it identify either
the microspheres or the bead itself or
the reporter die which is captured on
the detection antibody
which then provides the quantitation of
an individual analytes on each
microsphere
so this technology enables you to
Multiplex the measurement of up to 80
Targets in every single well on the
bottom right hand side you can see the
workflow of the assay it's a very simple
eliza-like workflow
as mentioned we recently launched the
3d4 wall
format of these asses as well and here
is a few key highlights of these assets
they provide very high throughput
without compromising the sensitivity
they have a high convenience in terms of
the workflow as mentioned very
eliza-like workflow you can scale from
96 to three to four well formats with
confidence and without losing
performance and in general they have a
very high and robust performance and
exemplified by the R square values for
example for looking at the standards
and I'm very excited
to let you know that we also launched a
new uh format for even more convenience
which is the lyophilized beat format
this format allows you to directly add
your sample to the plate which comes
pre-filled with biophilized um beats so
this is something that we recently
launched and is um even offers you even
more convenience to run your high
throughput essays and this is in
addition to our standard liquid beat
form idea where you would add the beads
into the plate
importantly we also provide a free of
charge data analysis solution for these
assays the invitrogen for cardaplex data
analysis app which is available on the
thermal Fisher connect platform
this enables the analysis of our of the
data that come from the prokato Plex
Multiplex protein assays and these data
can be acquired either on any luminex
instrument or also the so-called
paroplex instruments
you can immediately start your biomarker
profiling by easily assigning lot
specifics essay in this data analysis
tool to your Multiplex data this
intuitive cloud-based analysis tool
allows to analyze both 96 and 3D for
well
data you should take a look at the
analysis tool here and the link is
mentioned on the bottom of this page and
you can easily get publication ready
data out of this tool or for any of your
internal or external presentations
for the remainder of this presentation
we'll focus on the quantity in Flex
essay for Multiplex gene expression
analysis in showcase automation options
for this High throughput assay this
essay relies on the so-called branched
DNA technology which amplifies the
signal and not the target as you do with
your traditional and qpcr gene
expression technology it is a cost
effective and reliable and scalable
method for General gene expression
studies but it also used
extensively in high throughput
screenings to measure Gene signatures
and biomarkers for example in drug
discovery
here are some of the key benefits as
mentioned earlier again you do not need
to purify your RNA you go right from
your light state or homogen it into the
essay and we offer some prep
um kits for both tissues and cells as
well as blood and even ffpe
you can do a multiplexing with up to 80
Targets in the 96034 while
um plate and you can also detect very
subtle changes because this is a linear
s you can also measure percentage
differences not just fault differences
as mentioned um this is available in 3D
for our format I'm going to show you
here High throughput cell screening
workflow using the quantity in Plex 3d4
well
um as they use a detailed overview of
the complete essay workflow including
Hands-On and incubation time for day one
and day two of the essay this essay has
an overnight incubation on day one as
you can see from the number of steps
while Hands-On time is fairly minimal
there are various touch points in the
workflow that require lab technician
time and effort for incubation washes
pipetting transfer steps
um Etc
here on the left is a simplified view of
the different SC steps for day one and
day two that I just showed you in more
detail on the previous Slide the
adoption of equipment and automated
equipment for simplifying this workflow
is more and more
um
required by our customers so on the
right hand side I'm gonna I'm showing
you some required or suggested equipment
to run the essay in either 96 or 3D
forward format you will see that in the
3D 404 form and it's definitely
recommended that you use equipment for
the different steps be it be it for
liquid handling or for dispensing and
then definitely for magnetic plate
washing
and then you have your instruments
listed on the on the bottom right hand
side that are able to measure either the
96 well played format or the 3D full
well plates
um format so our customers are more and
more switching to high throughput
applications and we saw a great
opportunity in looking into more
automation solutions for this uh
established quantity implex as well as
the poconoplex um essays by the way
so before we talk about our approaches
of automating these assets I want to
show you a couple of published examples
of how our customers have already done a
semi automation of these quantity implex
essay and use them for high throughput
screening so in this first example
that's on the screen right now
um Dana hay and colleague studied
cytokine driven goblet cell metaplasia
in the lung which by the way is a
Hallmark of chronic lung disease and
lack Securities treatment to dates using
the high throughput quantity in Plex 3d4
will asset for compounds Library screen
and 3D bronchospheres they were able to
screen almost 5 000 compounds and sounds
that Notch two is required for this
gobbled cell metaplasia in the lung so
more specifically They concluded that
the inhibition of the notch to pathway
prevents goblet cell metaplasia induced
by a broad range of the stimuli that
they measured and they're also now
exploring future therapeutic users in
preventing in this condition in Airway
diseases so in summary the quantity
implex 3d4 while screen was extremely
helpful to
um to reach their goals
in the second example here ferreridol
used the quantity in Plex High through
essay for biomarker studies in ipsc
derived retinol pigment cells
they started out by establishing
establishing the essay first in a 96
well format and thoroughly validating
the essay in that format before they
then scaled up
um the essay to run it in a 3d4 while
high throughput format to increase both
their throughput and decrease the
required sample input which was very
important for them
the authors found a significant
correlation of the multiplex gene
expression data from those quantity
inflex assays with the standard qpcr
measurements and then they concluded
that this high throughput as it provides
with the basis for their compound screen
to study the retinal pigment epithelium
function and maturation
and in exploring future treatments for
several retinal degenerative diseases
that are out there so these high
throughput studies obviously generate a
vast amount of data that needs to be
analyzed so before going into more lab
automation Solutions I also um want to
mention that we have a data analysis
tool for our quantine Plex assays
um as well and again I can't
overemphasize the data analysis is a a
big step in the workflow and cannot be
overlooked so our free of charge
quantity and flex data analysis software
which is also available on the thermo
official connect platform that to
analyze your data
from gene expression with an easy to use
workflow that provides customization
capabilities for for example
normalization in your general data
analysis needs for your Multiplex data
so this
um data that comes from the quantity in
Plex assets can be analyzed in this
software and then after you're done with
the basic analysis in this software they
can even be exported into the so-called
transcriptome analysis console software
that some of you might be familiar with
from microarray analysis and there we
enable the generation of heat Maps PCA
and volcano plots or looking into
pathway analysis some of the key
features are mentioned at the bottom in
the table at the bottom of this of this
slide
and by the way I want to remind you that
we have the similar
um analysis tool also for our
procardoplex
um assays
so when looking at options on how to
automate certain steps and ultimately
um the whole workflow for luminix based
essays if we looked no further than our
film official lab automation Group which
has tons of experience with automating
various assays and whole workflows
as you can see in this overview slide so
here we're looking from manual all the
way to very high throughput
capacity systems from left to right
um obviously you're gonna increase your
um
your time to results and you're going to
decrease your time to result
um and obviously the date the data that
you can measure increases with higher
throughput capacities
so with this I will hand it over to my
colleague from our lab automation group
um Dr Bonnie story for the remainder of
the presentation thank you very much
thank you Stefan oh hi everyone I am
Bonnie part of the lab automation team
so
to help everyone understand where lab
automation fits in the expansive
portfolio of thermal facial scientific
we were acquired over 20 years ago and
since then we have a dedicated business
within thermal and have since then
formed active collaborations and
connections throughout Thermo scientific
we can boast of the largest install base
of over 2600 installations worldwide
over the past 25 years
we are and this has been possible as we
have a dedicated r d application
scientist team as well as sales and
service support partnering and providing
personalized solutions for all our
customers needs
the lab automation team is based in
Burlington Ontario Canada and in
langenvel Bowl Germany and we also have
a global presence where we are
substantially expanded our local
resource and support infrastructure
worldwide particularly in Europe and in
Asia
so when thinking about automating your
lab people often thought of it as a high
throughput screening tool but we and our
customers can assure you that automation
goes well beyond increasing throughput
so starting with the most obvious
benefit automation reduces scientists
time on manual tasks such that it frees
up time to allow you to focus on higher
cognitive things that robots don't do
well well at least not yet
and this obviously results in maximizing
throughput and instrument uptime such
that your work hour is still a day sorry
your work day is still a eight hour work
day but the experiments and workflows
run 24 hours or even over the weekend
and automation also reduces errors so
thereby providing reproducible quality
results which are publication ready
the flexibility to scale and connect
data for traceability creativity would
be the only limiting factor for your
automation platform
in here I would
land a worker and our current
capabilities
so starting at the bottom which is the
base layer
the base layer is made up of automated
devices
we offer a series of automated
incubators called cytomath
and are capable to integrate over 450
instruments which are automatable Thermo
and non-thermal devices
we remain brand agnostic
as long as the instrument's automatable
we can work with it
the middle or the second layer consists
of our configurable automation
essentially with robotic movers where we
offer stationary mowers
which could be stationary or they could
be on a linear track
we also have tall movers uh gaining
space in the vertical axis
we also have industrial arms which is
preferably chosen if the payload is
higher and the work is intensive
they also have smart technology which is
touch enabled such that when you touch
the handles of our smart shelf or Smart
Cuts they respond by disengaging the
devices from the automation platform
allowing their safe use in an offline
manner or if they need to be transported
and the top or the brain controlling it
all these layers is the thermoscientific
momentum work so scheduling software or
momentum for short
so momentum allows communication across
and between all these layers and also
between cloud and external repositories
such as limits
core value to our portfolio as you can
see is collaboration and flexibility
we like to think of automation as a
journey and in our experience we've come
across four Journeys that our customers
have been through
the very first on the left is the
instrument loading Journey and that is
when someone is looking to automate a
simple instrument loading and unloading
setup for their workflow
it's just to displace the manual loading
and unloading of one or two instruments
as we move from left to right uh the
requirements get more complex and the
systems get more advanced
so as we move to the simple workflow the
second one
uh the customer is typically looking to
automate a larger assay or a slightly
bigger workflow or maybe three or four
automatable instruments
moving further right which is the
configurable platform Journey here we
are looking for a more configurable and
flexible solution to connect more
processes and adapt to changing
workflows in the lab
this is what we are going to be focusing
on for the corner genes like sapphics
and then there's also the large system
Journey where you're looking to automate
and run different experiments and
workflows such as maybe cell culture
Eliza
High throughput screening for example
all on the same platform and maybe in
parallel
so I would say the recent uh brilliant
example of the lab automation success
Journey
has been the automated amplitude
workflow for our attack paths our score
V2 assay for detecting the covid for
detecting covert anti-population scale
so as you can see that's as we move from
left to right the systems get more
configurable the requirements get more
complex the systems get more advanced
and this functionality increases rapidly
yeah so for automating the quantity in
Flex assay we chose the thermoscientific
inspired collaborative automation
platform which brings configurable and
interactive solutions to your lab
the Inspire platform has a flexible
vertical orientation to save space
and right in the middle or the center of
it is the Inspire of the Inspire the
thermoscientific Spinnaker XT robotic
Hoover it's a tall mover with a 360
degree workspace
such that all the instruments can be
surrounded across it
the robotic mover has built-in barcode
reading for sample tracking it has
Vision Based Teaching and on-the-fly
healing
the key features are that it's highly
intuitive the Inspire platform is
designed to work collaboratively
alongside you
you can easily access instruments for
offline use and just have easily return
them back
in case the instrument is needed before
it was returned this is the software
actually prompts you and alerts you to
bring it back in
it's highly Interactive the unique smart
handle technology provides added lens
instrument status updates and provides
touch control for instrument access and
controls
highly versatile
the platforms like this flexible design
allows saving space and also allows you
to configure the right solution for your
evolving lab needs
so the benefits are pretty much like
popped out of automation it decreases
Hands-On time maximizes throughput
enhances reproducible results it's
flexible to scale and evolve and also
save space just because of its vertical
structure
on this slide we are showing a high
level graphical representation of the
quantity in Flex assay run in an
automated fashion by the momentum
software on the Inspire platform
each step of the protocol is being
automated by various instruments
so beginning from the very left the
liquid Handler provides a one is to one
stamp from the input plate and the
standard Pages then transferred to a
silo
it is then incubated in the automated
incubator cytomat for the required
amount of time
once incubation time has been reached
the Plato's retrieved and transferred to
the plate pillow followed by its
movement to be played the Spencer or
washer
where different reagents are dispensed
on it and aspirated off
the player's subsequently we feel and
this goes through multiple Loops of
incubation
and at the very end when after the end
of the last incubation steps the plate
is agitated on a plate Shaker and then
it's transferred to the luminex reader
of your choice on the top right
and this entire process is controlled by
the by momentum software
so at the core of this automation is our
momentum scheduling software it is a
highly intuitive software for automating
your scientific workflows in High
Fidelity using drag and drop
functionality requiring absolutely no
coding knowledge
it is a data driven bi-directional
scheduler which means as actively
communicates with each device and
logically takes the next step based on
the inputs it receives
it is highly Dynamic making on-the-fly
decisions to situations some of them are
inbuilt and others can be added while
you design your experiment
it is highly scalable
a single software being able to control
multiple devices multiple robots and
also simultaneously communicating with
external repositories such as Lynch
it is highly capable
with an ever-growing library of over 450
devices thermal and non-formal
instruments
here is a small glimpse of what what
goes on in the background between our
internal groups to ensure that every
protocol detail is accounted for
accurately
this is the same protocol from the
earlier slides but Estep has been
cross-referenced against internal assay
performance data to provide our
customers with the confidence that they
are investing in a cohesive future-proof
automated solution
when considering who to partner with you
have many options to choose from and we
Thermo Fisher Scientific collaborate
internally to provide a cross-functional
solution for unprecedented value like
this example here
the automation of the quantities like
sassy is a collaboration between two
groups
that to solve our customers challenges
and support their ongoing success
this was achieved by unprecedented
access to internal resources from both
the quantity and pro part of Lex asset
teams as well as the labor automation
development teams to produce a solution
that satisfied not only their asset
performance characteristics but also
their evolving needs
so here in uh three solutions were
device and collaboration
with the quantity in teams Pro Cargo
team and lab automation group and these
three options represent the level of
scalability and flexibility
the platforms for all three solutions
are Inspire automation platform based
that means they're vertically integrated
for saving space
and access to all the instruments on in
an offline mode is easy to manage
the one on the left the single side map
system on the left it provides
self-contained protocol automation for
quantity and pro cardoplex acid both
where the input sample plate was just
passed into the system and finally the
data is automatically uploaded to your
limbs when the run is complete
in the middle of the screen is the Dual
cytomap system built based on the first
one with the only addition of an
additional cytomat incubator allowing
both incubators to be set at static
temperatures for a considerable increase
in throughput
finally the one on the right the Dual
high capacity fibromat system it
leverages on the side axis of the
Inspire platform
it has a slightly larger footprint for
increased capacity and with the addition
of Carousel which provides increased
ambient storage and which translates to
increased walk away time
so this slide shows different options
highlighting the flexibility to scale
and your throughput requirements
uh if you'd like to learn more about
watch the fun and I have presented today
please do visit the links tomofisher.com
luminex and thermofisher.com Inspire to
learn more
and with that we would like to thank you
all for your time and are ready to take
any questions from the audience now
and I want to thank you both Dr Yale
Bauer and Dr story for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have
any questions you want to ask please do
so now just click on that ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen
so let's get started it looks like we
already have some great questions coming
in from our audience
our first question how many targets can
I look at simultaneously
yeah I can take that question so
um for both our quantity and Plex and
our procado Plex essay you can really
measure 80 different targets per well
and that is both in the 96 and 3d4 well
format and as mentioned earlier there is
different off-the-shelf panels
um available for different areas of
biology and a lot of different
Immunology areas for procardoplex and
then on the quantity and flex side it's
really a lot of flexibility all we need
to know is the up to 80 targets that you
want to measure and we can custom build
um that asset for you but as also
mentioned we are about to launch uh a
lot of different
um off-the-shelf and pre-designed panels
for quantity and Plex as well so stay
tuned
and thank you so much and what is the
sensitivity of the quantity Gene Plex
assay
yeah great question um I haven't been
able to to talk about the details of the
essay but thanks for for asking good
question so the sensitivity is really
dependent on the individual expression
um rate of your targets a general
um threshold that we usually put out is
there needs to be a thousand copies in
your sample of a particular Target so
that the assay can detect it so either
you have a thousand cells with one copy
of your target that's expressed or you
have one one single cell with a thousand
copies of that specific Target and the
assay will be able to give you a
reliable signal
thank you so much I want to thank our
audience for these great questions
our next audience member says I'm doing
a large cell culture screen with
thousands of compounds how do I do my
sample prep for quantity Gene Plex
analysis
yeah I can take that one as well and
still a quantity implex
um related so while certainly our lab
automation group could help you with
setting up the sample prep in terms of
the steps in automating
um the steps for licenses incubation and
then eventually the you know RNA
extraction is necessary
um
um the sampler prep procedure for
quantity implex uh in general is is
um very straightforward we offer sample
prep solutions for both tissues
um as well as cells together with
protocols for different tissue types as
well as for different cell types on top
of that we also have solutions for blood
samples
and I also want to mention it is also
possible if you already have the RNA
extracted you can run that purified RNA
directly in the assay
as well but again the big benefit is you
do not have to extract the RNA you can
go straight from your cell lysate into
your
assay and the cell screening or cell
cultural screening is the the biggest
tool for high throughput assays so in a
hypothetical scenario you would end your
screening experiments you would take off
your supernatant maybe wash the cells a
couple times and then add the lysis
buffer then incubate
the the samples for like 30 minutes at a
certain temperature and then you're
ready to have your life State ready for
the for the acid so you go straight into
the assay from there
sorry that was a very detailed answer
but I hope that was helpful of course
we have time for a couple of more
questions for people just starting out
on an automation Journey what do you
suggest is the first step
okay
um I can take that question
um thank you for that question it is
really it's a nice question so I'd
probably like to answer that with two
perspectives so uh at an organizational
level
uh the first step would be to identify
where you would like to start off in
your automation journey and also look
ahead as to where would you like to
reach and then maybe engage in a
conversation but at a More lab-centric
Level a good way would be to identify
either critical experiments or steps
which will benefit by Automation and
based on that start a conversation with
one of the sales or application
scientists and they will be able to
identify the granular details of your
journey better
yeah
I hope that answers
yes it does thank you so much now you
listed a number of instruments placed on
the Inspire platform is it possible to
use the different instruments than the
ones that were mentioned for example
using a different Plate Reader or a
plate Steeler or peeler
yes oh for sure so the Inspire platform
is highly configurable and flexible so
for this particular asset Rachel with
these instruments based on what worked
best but yes you can or like a customer
can choose any instrument and we are
brand agnostic so it doesn't matter
which peeler or sealer of a treat or
you'd like to use any and every
instrument as long as it's automatable
can be added onto the Inspire platform
thank you both so much I want to thank
you for your time today would you like
to provide any closing remarks for our
audience before we go
um yeah thanks for for having us thanks
um for luminex to invite us
um to speak on their behalf at this uh
great event I hope you all enjoyed our
presentation and learned something new
from us today please get in touch if you
um have any further questions
um and I just want to emphasize again
that this um this project that we
presented today was a great celebration
uh internally a film official scientific
between our essay um as a developer
group in our lab automation group where
we work together to come up with
solutions for our customers to run the
assay in a higher throughput eventually
get to the data earlier and and move
their lead candidates further in the
drug development pipeline which
hopefully benefits all of us at some
point
well I want to thank you both Dr
yelbauer and Dr sorry for your time
today and for your important research
and before we go I want to thank our
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions I'd also
like to thank our sponsors luminix a DSR
and Company for sponsoring today's
webinar and questions we did not have
time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by our speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration and this webcast can be
viewed on demand for two years until May
18 2024 Labyrinth will alert you via
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care everyone
goodbye
thank you thank you